House of the Dragon Episode 4 is about secs,
secrets and lies – characters make dramatic
emotional choices that may have “unwanted
consequences”.
The episode starts at Storm’s End, the castle
of House Baratheon.
We hear thunder rumbling and wind gusting
in the background, because this place is famous
for its storms.
The winds roar up from the Narrow Sea, and
slam into the walls of Storm’s End.
According to legend, Storm’s End was built
by Durran Godsgrief – the gods kept destroying
his castles so he rebuilt them stronger until
he finally built Storm’s End, a castle strong
enough and magic enough to withstand the fury
of the gods.
The Lord of Storm’s End is Boremund Baratheon.
We saw Boremund speak up for Rhaenys Targaryen
at the tournament in Episode 1, because Boremund
is Rhaenys’ uncle.
Boremund is one of the great lords of Westeros,
ruling the stormlands – like the Starks
rule the north, and the Lannisters rule the
westerlands.
Rhaenyra is here to find a husband.
She’s on tour visiting castles to meet some
single men.
Noble families often have tours like this
to find a marriage partner.
The books describe one king meeting a thousand
single girls in one day – and it’s described
as a Cattle Show, cause the girls are all
lined up like farm animals.
So, it’s not exactly romantic, and Rhaenyra
is not impressed by these men.
This secsy single is from House Dondarrion
– the family of Beric Dondarrion in Game
of Thrones.
Rhaenyra is not interested in his dry moat,
but the Dondarrion mentions Rhaenyra’s great-grandmother,
Queen Alysanne, the wife of King Jaehaerys,
who once visited the Dondarrion castle, Blackhaven.
There, Alysanne was enthralled by a Dondarrion
who played sad songs on his harp.
Blackhaven is also where Criston Cole is from.
Criston’s dad worked for the Dondarrions
as a steward.
And Criston fought with the Dondarrions against
Dornish incursions.
The next candidate is a boy from House Blackwood,
in the riverlands.
The Blackwoods are one of the only families
in the south who worship the Old Gods, like
the Starks do.
The Blackwood gets insulted by this guy from
House Bracken.
Because the Blackwoods and the Brackens have
an ancient blood feud – these families have
hated and fought each other for thousands
of years.
The Blackwoods say that the Brackens poisoned
their sacred weirwood tree.
King Jaehaerys tried to make peace between
these families but it didn’t last.
At one point, the Blackwoods and Brackens
fight for control of a pair of hills called
the Teats, and they argue over whose boobs
the hills are named after – are they Barba
Bracken’s Teats or Missy Blackwood’s Teats.
In the main series, the Brackens side with
the Lannisters, while the Blackwoods support
the Starks.
And Lord Tytos Blackwood has a cool cloak.
So the Blackwoods are fan favourites among
book readers.
But when the Bracken insults the Blackwood
kid, Rhaenyra says she likes the Bracken – seems
like Rhaenyra is attracted to bad boys and
bullies – like her uncle Daemon.
Rhaenyra still wears the necklace that Daemon
gave her.
The Blackwood kid has enough of the Bracken’s
insults, so they fight, and the Blackwood
kills the Bracken.
This is another example of random violence
breaking out when it’s not meant to – like
those knights killing each other in Episode
1.
Like Rhaenys said, there are a lot of young
dumb men in the realm who are eager to fight
for glory after these long decades of peace.
Some of these other eligible bachelors are
from houses Tully, Swann, Frey, and House
Mudd.
And the Mudd is weird, because House Mudd
went extinct.. about four thousand years ago.
The castle of the Mudd kings has been a ruin
for so long that no one remembers its name.
So this guy telling Rhaenyra he’s a Mudd
is kinda like telling your first date that
you’re an Egyptian pharaoh.
That said, in the books there are some characters
who claim to be descendants of House Mudd.
Including the mysterious Jenny of Oldstones,
who Podrick sings a song about in Game of
Thrones.
Rhaenyra gets sick of the speed dating, and
heads back to King’s Landing, even though
she was meant to keep touring for two more
months.
Daemon Targaryen also returns, after he was
off at war on the Stepstones.
Daemon swoops his dragon dangerously over
Rhaenyra’s ship, because Daemon is desperate
for attention, and never misses the chance
to cause some chaos.
In this episode, Daemon’s disruptive behaviour
rocks the boat both literally and metaphorically.
When Daemon returns, the mood at court is
tense, cause last time Daemon was here, his
brother King Viserys exiled him and removed
him as heir to the Throne.
Then Daemon practically rebelled against Viserys,
and stole a dragon egg.
So now Viserys tries to show strength and
authority by meeting Daemon in the throne
room, wearing his crown, and holding the royal
sword Blackfyre.
Daemon presents the hammer of the Crabfeeder,
who Daemon killed last episode.
This is the hammer that the Crabfeeder used
to nail people to the beach to die.
Daemon says he copied the Crabfeeder’s brutal
execution method, using to kill thousands
of Triarchy men.
So like when he killed and mutilated people
with his gold cloaks, Daemon again uses violence
to create fear.
Daemon says to add the hammer to the Iron
Throne, to join the other weapons of the Targaryens’
defeated enemies – Barristan says the same
thing in Game of Thrones.
Daemon wears a crown, and calls himself “King
of the Narrow Sea”, which is the ocean north
of the Stepstones.
It is provocative to call himself king, as
though he’s the equal of Viserys.
But then Daemon kneels and gives up his crown.
So Daemon makes his homecoming dramatic and
theatrical, seeking glory and validation for
his accomplishments.
In the books, Daemon’s return is even more
dramatic – Daemon swoops down on his dragon
during a tournament to give Viserys his crown.
Viserys forgives Daemon’s crimes, and the
brothers reunite.
They have a boozy garden party and talk about
their childhood – the books say that Viserys
loves Daemon because he remembers the fun
adventurous boy Daemon was, and tries to ignore
the violent selfish man he’s become.
Viserys mentions their mother Alyssa, and
how she was rebel who broke rules.
Alyssa was a tomboy, kinda like Arya Stark.
She had a crooked broken nose from playing
with a wooden sword, and her eyes were two
different colours.
Alyssa’s two favourite activities were having
secs with her husband Baelon, and riding her
dragon Meleys.
Alyssa took her sons Viserys and Daemon on
dragon rides when they were just babies.
Then Alyssa died young from childbirth complications.
And now Rhaenys Targaryen rides Alyssa’s
dragon Meleys.
Rhaenyra and Alicent start to reconnect.
Cause Alicent feels lonely.
Everyone treats her as a queen, not as a friend.
She feels trapped in this castle, making babies
all day – Alicent has now given birth to
a daughter, her second child after Aegon.
Alicent envies Rhaenyra’s freedom in getting
to choose a husband – Alicent didn’t get
to choose her husband – her father Otto
pushed to be with Viserys.
Rhaenyra had been angry at Alicent for suddenly
marrying her dad, and becoming a political
rival.
But now she’s sympathetic, and they hold
hands again, like they used to.
This moment of friendship makes it more painful
later when their relationship is threatened
again.
Rhaenyra speaks with Daemon in the Valyrian
language, which is their way of speaking secretly
and intimately.
Rhaenyra tells Daemon that she doesn’t want
to get married because she doesn’t want
to be trapped and lonely like Alicent, and
she doesn’t want to die in childbirth like
her mother Aemma did – and like her grandmother
Alyssa died of childbirth, and her other grandmother
Daella also died in childbirth.
But Daemon says you shouldn’t live alone,
or in fear, or else you’ll miss out on life.
You’ve got to take risks, break rules, do
what you want.
Daemon’s life philosophy sounds inspiring,
but Daemon also has a hidden motivation – Daemon
hopes to have secs with Rhaenyra, and to marry
her.
So he plays the creepy uncle, giving Rhaenyra
wine, telling her she’s matured.
Rhaenyra asks why Daemon returned, what does
he want?
And it seems like what he wants is Rhaenyra.
We see a meeting of the small council.
Tyland Lannister is now master of ships to
replace Corlys.
And now Rhaenyra is on the council, she has
a small council ball and everything.
Looks like Viserys is finally including Rhaenyra,
so she can learn politics, which is /super
important for the heir to the Throne.
The council is worried about Corlys Velaryon.
Despite Daemon calling himself King of the
Narrow Sea, it sounds like Corlys now controls
the region.
And now, Corlys plans to marry his daughter
Laena to the son of the Sealord of Braavos.
Braavos is a city in the east – it’s where
Arya Stark joined the Faceless Men in Game
of Thrones.
<Westeros usually gets along okay with Braavos.
But Braavos is powerful – they’re very
rich, and have a strong navy.
So Otto is worried that if Braavos allies
with the Velaryons with their wealth and ships,
their combined strength could dominate the
Narrow Sea, and become a threat to the Targaryens.
Corlys is still angry that Viserys rejected
Laena’s marriage proposal.
Otto says he learned about Corlys’ plans
from his brother Hobert in Oldtown.
Which is weird.
Why would Hobert in Oldtown know about Corlys
Velaryon’s plans?
Well Oldtown is the home of the Citadel of
the maesters.
And the maesters send the letters between
the lords of Westeros.
So maybe the Hightowers are using the maesters
to spy on lords across the realm.
There are hints in the books of a maester
conspiracy.
That night, Daemon leaves a message for Rhaenyra.
It shows her a secret passage out of her room
in the Red Keep.
The Red Keep was built by King Maegor the
Cruel.
And Maegor filled the Keep with secret passages,
hidden doors and steps.
There are a tunnels to escape the castle in
case of attack.
There are spaces in the walls so that child
spies can listen to conversations.
After the Red Keep was built, Maegor had all
the construction workers killed, so that his
secret passages would stay secret.
In Game of Thrones, Varys knows these passages,
and uses them free Tyrion.
In Hot D, Daemon knows the passages.
Previously, we saw him spying on the small
council from some hidden place.
Now he uses a passage to sneak Rhaenyra out
of the castle, for a night on the town of
freedom and fun.
Disguised in different clothes, and with a
hat, Rhaenyra is freed from the restrictions
of being a princess.
She’s thrilled to be mistaken for a boy.
It’s like when Arya pretends to be a boy,
and experiences life as a common person.
We see a street performer doing what looks
like fire magic.
Or it might just be a cheap trick.
In the books, Melisandre mentions using flammable
powders instead of real magic.
But in Book 2, Daenerys sees a fire magic
performance, and Quaithe says the magic is
real.
She says that magic is now more powerful because
Daenerys hatched dragons.
It seems that when there are dragons in the
world, magic is stronger.
In the time of Hot D, there are lots of dragons,
so this might be an especially magical time
in Westeros.
Maybe that’s why Viserys has prophetic dreams.
Rhaenyra and Daemon see a street theatre show,
like the one Arya sees in Braavos.
This reveals how the common people feel about
the royal family.
We see Daemon in his armour, and Rhaenyra
in her dress.
And baby Aegon with his dragon toy.
We learn that many common people want baby
Aegon to inherit the Throne, not Rhaenyra
– because Aegon is male, while Rhaenyra
is a “feeble” female.
Rhaenyra says the common people don’t matter,
their desires are of “no consequence”.
Rhaenyra used those same words, “no consequence”,
when she told Viserys that her own desires
don’t matter.
Rhaenyra feels like no one cares about her
opinion, so why should she care about any
else’s?
But we saw in Game of Thrones that the common
people do matter – when they turn against
the Lannisters, they start a deadly riot,
and support the sparrows overthrowing Cersei.
Good politicians know that to be a successful
ruler, you’ve got to win over the people.
Rhaenyra steals food from a street vendor,
just for the thrill of breaking rules.
And she bumps into Harwin Strong – the son
of Lyonel Strong, who we met last episode.
Harwin has joined the gold cloaks City Watch
while his family’s at court.
And Daemon was once the commander of the gold
cloaks.
So Harwin lets Rhaenyra continue on her secret
night-time adventure.
Daemon takes Rhaenyra to a secs club, to show
her that secs is not just an obligation in
marriage to produce babies.
Secs can be for pleasure and passion.
These opulent orgies fit with the theme of
decadence – this is a time of prosperity,
indulgence and carefree pleasure – like
Rome before the fall.
While Rhaenyra enjoys fun and freedom, Queen
Alicent is stuck at home, looking cold and
lonely.
Alicent gives a sponge bath to her husband
Viserys, whose body is falling apart from
the infection that started in his hand.
In the books, Alicent cared for the old king
Jaehaerys like this while he was sick, helping
to bathe and dress him.
The jester Mushroom claims that Alicent also
had secs with Jaehaerys.
There are also rumours that Alicent had secs
with Viserys before his wife Aemma died.
And Mushroom claims that Alicent lost her
virginity to Daemon.
So believe it or not, the books have even
more secret scandalous secs rumours than this
episode does.
Later, Viserys and Alicent have secs, and
Alicent gets no pleasure.
For her, secs is a duty where her body is
used to produce children.
We see Alicent fidgeting with her fingers
– a sign of anxiety and discomfort.
Afterwards, she sees a mouse or rat on the
bed – which might represent corruption and
sickness, or that Viserys has been eating
cheese in bed.
So while Alicent is trapped in a bad secsual
experience, Rhaenyra explores the pleasure
of her secsuality.
She and her uncle Daemon start hooking up.
And Rhaenyra’s into it.
But then Daemon stops, and just.. walks away.
According to the show’s creators, Daemon
wanted to shock Rhaenyra, he wanted to be
in control of this situation, but he was thrown
off when Rhaenyra was more passionate and
into this than he was.
Deep down Daemon knew that using Rhaenyra
was wrong.
So suddenly he felt impotent, unable to continue
– like previously when he stopped having
secs with Mysaria.
So Daemon leaves.
Rhaenyra is unsatisfied.
So when she gets back to the Keep, she playfully
flirts with Ser Criston, kisses him, and takes
off his Kingsguard armour.
Criston is reluctant because as a Kingsguard
knight, he has sworn to never have secs, and
he especially can’t have secs with the princess
– that’s treason.
In the books, a Kingsguard knight called Terrence
Toyne gets executed for the crime of having
secs with a king’s mistress.
A knight called Lucamore Strong, a relative
of Lyonel and Harwin Strong, was found to
have secretly had three wives and fathered
sixteen children while on the Kingsguard.
So King Jaehaerys had Lucamore’s penis cut
off and sent him to the Night’s Watch.
So Criston knows the danger here.
But.. he wants Rhaenyra.
And he may feel obligated to obey his princess.
So Criston feels deeply conflicted as he puts
down his white Kingsguard cloak.
In the books, a Kingsguard knight called Arys
has secs with Arianne Martell.
Arys doesn’t want to soil his white cloak
by having secs.
But Arianne says there’s no harm in love
– knights should be judged for how they
use their sword, not for how they use their
cock.
So Rhaenyra and Criston have secs, and it
feels playful and joyous as the princess loses
her virginity to the white knight.
The next morning, Rhaenyra is happy to see
Criston – maybe she wants to continue this
dangerous relationship.
Rhaenyra no longer wears Daemon’s necklace
– Criston is the one she wants now.
But Criston looks worried and distant, terrified
that he’ll be found out and punished.
A Song of Ice and Fire is full of these forbidden
romances – like Jon Snow and Ygritte – and
many of these relationships end in tragedy.
In the books, the jester Mushroom has a very
different version of what happened between
Rhaenyra, Criston and Daemon.
Mushroom claims that Rhaenyra originally wanted
Criston.
So Daemon gave Rhaenyra secs lessons to teach
Rhaenyra how to seduce Criston.
But, according to Mushroom, Criston rejected
Rhaenyra and kept to his Kingsguard vows.
A big theme of the book Fire & Blood is that
the historians are often wrong and don’t
know the real story of what happened behind
closed doors.
Daemon wakes up extremely hung over – looks
like he tried to drink enough to forget that
he macked on his niece.
Daemon’s ex-lover Mysaria gave him a place
to crash.
It sounds like Daemon and Mysaria haven’t
seen each other in years.
Mysaria reveals she’s no longer a secs worker
– she’s now a spymaster, known as the
White Worm.
Cause when Rhaenyra leaves the secs club,
she’s seen by a young boy.
And that boy then goes to Otto Hightower and
tells him that Rhaenyra had secs with Daemon.
Now the boy brings money back to Mysaria – payment
for the information.
So instead of selling secs, Mysaria now sells
secrets.
It’s like how Littlefinger in Game of Thrones
uses brothels both for selling secs, and for
spying.
But why would Mysaria tell Otto about Daemon
and Rhaenyra?
That’ll get Daemon in trouble.
Maybe Mysaria wants to hurt Daemon, as revenge
for abandoning her, and for using her in his
Dragonstone plots.
Otto says that Mysaria is a trusted source
of information, like they’ve been working
together for a while.
So maybe it was Mysaria who told Otto about
Daemon’s heir for a day speech in Episode
1.
Maybe she’s been working against Daemon
all along.
Then again, Daemon did want to be seen with
Rhaenyra at the secs club – he took off
Rhaenyra’s hat, so she’d be recognised.
So maybe Daemon wanted Mysaria to tell Otto
that he hooked up with Rhaenyra.
Cause if people think Rhaenyra’s been devirginized
by Daemon, it’s more likely he’ll be allowed
to marry Rhaenyra.
But does Mysaria know that Daemon wants Otto
to know?
The whole Mysaria situation is mysterious.
So Otto finds out that Daemon hooked up with
Rhaenyra.
And this is a big opportunity for him politically.
Because if he can discredit Rhaenyra and Daemon,
that makes it more likely that his grandson
Aegon will become heir to the Throne instead.
But Otto also knows that this news will hurt
Viserys, and the showrunners say that despite
all his plotting, Otto does love Viserys and
doesn’t want to hurt him.
Nonetheless, Otto tells Viserys that his daughter
had secs with his brother.
And Viserys get angry.
He accuses Otto of trying to undermine Rhaenyra
to get Aegon on the Throne – which is true.
Viserys finally starts to realise that his
trusted Hand is corrupt – just like his
actual hand is infected.
Alicent overhears this conversation.
So then Alicent confronts Rhaenyra about her
having secs with Daemon.
Alicent is angry because a princess having
secs out of wedlock is seen as a terrible
scandalous dishonour, not only to Rhaenyra
but to the whole royal family.
Rhaenyra losing her virginity makes her a
less desirable wife, which could make it harder
to make a good marriage alliance.
Incest and adultery are considered sins by
the Faith of the Seven, and Alicent is a devout
believer.
Some people like Daemon don’t care about
these rules – he thinks Targaryens can do
what they want.
But Alicent is a proper lady, she lives by
these rules.
She’s trapped in these rules.
So maybe Alicent feels envious of Rhaenyra.
It seems unfair that Rhaenyra gets to do what
she wants, while Alicent is trapped in a lonely
marriage with Viserys.
Alicent may also feel scared that if Rhaenyra
is punished and sent away, Alicent could lose
her only friend.
When Rhaenyra is faced with this dangerous
allegation, she lies.
She swears on her mother’s memory that Daemon
didn’t touch her.
Which he totally did.
Making a false oath like this is pretty bad
in Westeros – especially in front of a weirwood
tree.
Rhaenyra and Alicent don’t believe in the
Old Gods religion, but symbolically there’s
a sense that the Old Gods see Rhaenyra’s
lie.
How will Alicent react if she finds out this
lie?
Alicent and Rhaenyra’s relationship is probably
the longest and most intimate relationship
in both of their lives.
They grew up together, they love each other.
So secrets between them can leave deep painful
wounds.
Later, Alicent tells Viserys that she believes
Rhaenyra is innocent.
She sticks up for her friend.
Which makes it all the more tragic that Rhaenyra
lied.
Viserys confronts Daemon, angry at him for
having secs with Rhaenyra.
Of course, Daemon didn’t have secs with
Rhaenyra, but Daemon lets Viserys believe
that he did.
Cause if Rhaenyra is no longer a virgin, it’ll
be harder to marry her off – so Daemon says
he’ll marry Rhaenyra.
And this is a political move by Daemon.
Cause Rhaenyra is heir to the Throne.
As her husband, Daemon could potentially rule
Westeros.
So it looks like this was Daemon’s plan
all along – to use Rhaenyra to get the Throne,
and to piss off Viserys.
Daemon resents Viserys for exiling him, for
not making him Hand, for not giving him the
love and validation he wants.
Daemon succeeds in pissing off Viserys, but
he fails to get Rhaenyra as wife.
Viserys says no partly because Daemon is already
married to his estranged wife Rhea.
And while the Faith has accepted Targaryen
incest, the Faith is not okay with Targaryen
polygamy.
Viserys exiles Daemon again, tells him to
go back to his estranged wife in the Vale
and to never come back.
Then Viserys confronts Rhaenyra.
And he tells her that her.. personal desires
aren’t as important as the strength of the
Targaryen dynasty.
Because of Aegon the Conqueror’s dream,
his prophecy that the Targaryens will save
the world from the white walkers.
Aegon wrote a message on his Valyrian steel
dagger, that only appears when it’s in fire,
>like the One Ring.
And it says “From my blood...
come the prince that was promised... and his
will be the song of ice and fire”.
So – what does that mean?
The prince that was promised, or Azor Ahai,
is a prophesied hero, the chosen one who will
lead the war against the white walkers.
In the Game of Thrones show, Melisandre thinks
Stannis is the prince that was promised, then
she thinks it’s Jon, then she thinks both
Jon and Daenerys “have a role to play”.
So then Jon and Daenerys help in the battle
when Arya kills the Night King – using Aegon’s
Valyrian steel dagger.
In the books, the prophecy stuff is more complicated.
It’s said that the hero will use a burning
sword called Lightbringer that might be a
literal sword, or a metaphor for dragons or
something.
There are themes of sacrifice that might connect
to Jon killing Daenerys.
“the song of ice and fire” is a line from
Book 2, when Daenerys has a vision of her
brother Rhaegar.
Rhaegar says his son is the prince that was
promised, and “his is the song of ice and
fire”.
Rhaegar does change his mind a lot about who
the prince that was promised is, but there
are lots of hints that Rhaegar’s son Jon
Snow is probably the chosen one.
Jon is the son of an icy Stark and a fiery
Targaryen making him a song or a son of ice
and fire.
Ned Stark promises to protect Jon, which makes
Jon literally a prince that was promised.
So it looks like in the books, Jon will play
a bigger role in defeating the white walkers
– he won’t just shout at a dragon while
Arya saves the day like in the show.
But prophecies are ambiguous, and the book
series still isn’t finished, so it’s still
a mystery how the books will end.
The point of all this is that the Targaryen
Throne is a huge responsibility.
It’s not just about personal desires, it’s
about protecting the bloodline that will save
the world.
So Rhaenyra should not undermine their strength
and stability by rooting her uncle.
Viserys says the old king Jaehaerys would
have disinherited Rhaenyra for this.
Because Jaehaerys had similar trouble with
his daughter Saera, when Saera had secret
scandalous secs.
Jaehaerys was furious, said Saera was no longer
his daughter, and Saera ran off to a brothel
in the east.
Of course it is very unfair that women aren’t
allowed secsual freedom, while men can generally
root who they want without consequence.
Viserys says the time for childish rebellion
is over.
He says Rhaenyra she will marry Laenor Velaryon,
the son and heir of Lord Corlys, and the rider
of the dragon Seasmoke.
Marriage to Laenor will renew the Targaryen
alliance with the powerful Velaryons, to bring
new strength and unity to the royal family.
Rhaenyra reluctantly agrees to the marriage,
on the condition that Viserys remove Otto
as Hand of the King.
Rhaenyra knows that Otto is plotting against
her, trying to make Aegon heir instead of
her.
So Viserys agrees to remove his corrupt Hand.
So in this scene, Viserys and Rhaenyra both
agree to make the smart political moves for
the good of their house.
Cause the stakes are high.
If they don’t make the right alliances and
have secs with the right people, their dynasty
will fall, the white walkers will win, and
the world will end.
The drama in this story comes from the interconnection
of the personal, the political, and the magical.
Viserys confronts Otto, and talks about his
father, Baelon Targaryen – the husband and
brother of Alyssa.
Prince “Baelon the Brave” was a warrior
– he rode the great dragon Vhagar, and wielded
the Valyrian steel sword Dark Sister, now
used by Daemon.
Baelon became Hand of the King to his father,
King Jaehaerys.
And in the books, Baelon served as Hand for
over a year – he was effective, and popular
with lords and common folk.
But then Baelon died of a “burst belly”
– which might mean appendicitis.
So Otto Hightower became the new Hand.
Now, Viserys seems to suspect that Otto murdered
Baelon with poison or something, so that Otto
could become Hand.
Viserys is now deeply suspicious of Otto,
because Viserys has realised that Otto has
been manipulating him for years.
It was Otto’s plan for Alicent to hook up
Viserys, exploiting Viserys’ grief for his
dead wife, to serve Otto’s ambition to get
his daughter married to the king.
Viserys can no longer trust Otto, so he removes
him as Hand.
Though the Hightowers remain a powerful and
ambitious family.
Grand Maester Mellos brings Rhaenyra some
moon tea.
This is the Westerosi version of a morning-after
pill.
A plan B. Or plan tea.
So if Rhaenyra got pregnant last night, this’ll
end the pregnancy, to prevent any troublesome
royal bastards being born.
Mellos says that Viserys sent Rhaenyra the
tea.
But maybe Otto got Mellos to do it – Otto
doesn’t want Rhaenyra birthing any sons
who might claim the Throne instead of Aegon.
Mellos leaves, and the episode ends, so we
don’t know for sure if Rhaenyra drinks the
tea.
Maybe Criston Cole’s bastard son is growing
inside her.
The last words in the episode are “unwanted
consequences”.
Cause the characters make emotional decisions
that might come back to bite them – Daemon
hooks up with Rhaenyra, Rhaenyra hooks up
with Criston and lies to Alicent, Viserys
rejects Daemon and Otto, Mysaria spies for
Otto, and this Blackwood kills this Bracken
– all these acts could lead to bigger conflicts
later on.
King Viserys is getting sicker and weaker
each episode, and when he dies, there will
be multiple conflicting claimants to his Throne.
There’s a shot of rats on a dragon skull,
like scavengers feasting on the corpse of
House Targaryen.
Everyone’s choices now could have “unwanted
consequences”, shaping the conflicts to
come.
If you want to know more about Baelon the
Brave and Alyssa and Saera in the reign of
Jaehaerys, the full story is told in Fire
& Blood, chapters 10 and 11.
You can get Fire & Blood, or any other audiobook,
for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching.
Please like and subscribe, and check out the
podcasts linked below.
And thanks to the Patrons, including Maggie
Brockway, TomCrow, KustkampKonrad, Juan Camilo
Ruiz, Theodor Zen, Matthew Slipenchuk, and
N00b F00.
Cheers.